un élève qui braquent un pistolet à air
comprimé sur son enseignante et la
menace en pleine classe raison une vidéo
amateur devenue virale sur les réseaux
sociaux et qui a choqué toute la france
le lycée edouard branly de créteil
n'était pourtant pas connu pour être
particulièrement violent ces élèves ne
s'explique toujours par l'incident
comprenez avec les professeurs tu cites
ouzou jiefu plus que ça se reproduise ce
genre de comportement c'est tout ce que
c'est inadmissible dont ici l'événement
qui s'est déroulé ici a beaucoup fait
réagir dans les milieux enseignant il a
fait libérer la parole et fait réaliser
aussi à bien les professeurs qu'ils sont
loin d'être les seuls à vivre au
quotidien des situations d'urgence sur
twitter il se sont vidés le coeur ils
ont raconté leur expérience et la
difficulté à se faire entendre de la
hiérarchie qui ne veut pas faire de
vagues
cet enseignant de géographie à parler du
coup de poing au visage
reçu par une collègue et de l'absence de
réaction de la direction
nous l'avons retrouvé non loin du
collège où elle enseigne en banlieue
parisienne
mais elle souhaite garder l'anonymat par
peur des représailles
l'élève qui a agressé une heure après
était toujours dans l'établissement sont
sans sanction pour protester les
professeurs ont cessé d'enseigner
jusqu'à la fin de la journée on a refusé
de faire court après après cet incident
ce que la direction n'a pas apprécié et
très mal répondu femmes ont cette fois
très mal répond une violence ordinaire
quotidienne et surtout une absence de
soutien qui minent le moral de bien des
enseignants les relations avec ma
direction
m'empêche de dormir cette année on fait
beaucoup serré les coudes c'est la même
raison qui a poussé à l'iss a quitté
l'éducation nationale après six ans à
enseigner dans une série d'écoles
secondaires tout plus difficiles les
unes que les autres
j'ai le droit salle cuts va [ __ ] ta
mère six années d' insulte de rejet de
l'autorité six amis surtout confrontés à
une hiérarchie qui ne la soutient pas
souvent la réponse c'était à main dans
ce cas là il faudra réfléchir à ce que
vous avez pu faire en amont pour que la
situation on arrive là moi je me suis
senti abandonné j'ai vraiment eu
l'impression qu'on me dise tu es tout
seul dans ton bateau et tu te
débrouilles pour ramener la vidéo virale
et la mobilisation en ligne ont poussé
le gouvernement à réagir
promettant une réponse plus ferme
parlant même de déployer des policiers
et des gendarmes dans les écoles de
présence physique de forces de l'ordre
dans l'établissement la mixité une
réponse loin de satisfaire les syndicats
d'enseignants se contente de notre côté
c'est qu'on sorte de la réponse coup de
com à un fait divers et qu'on rentre
dans un vrai projet pour le climat
scolaire pour l'ambiance dans les
collèges et les lycées fermes pour
lutter contre la violence selon les
enseignants il vaut toujours mieux
prévenir que guérir
ici jean françois bélanger a du canada
créteil